so a pitcher's night here you would
think
cool night first night good night to
pitch
the chicago cubs will turn to you
darvish
who has won each of his last three
starts just two runs over 20 innings he
has struck out
22 batters that's a .90 era in that time
frame
so colton wong will lead it off the
cardinals second baseman
a liner right to rizzo for the out
tommy edmonds switch hitting shortstop
edmonds
strikes out two out single for paul
goldschmidt and carpenter is trying to
keep the line moving trying to get brad
miller to the plate
he got him that time two strikeouts in
the first
one out now dylan carlson carlson
back in left field
and that's up the middle base hit for
carlson like so
now it's dexter fowler hitting 308. and
fowler hits it on the ground beats the
shift
and let's see carlson running around
second now on his way to third
easily and runners at the corners here
for the cardinals
and now matt wieders looking for his
first hit
of 20 20. just taking rbi would be nice
there's a ground ball they'll get one
two and that gets darvish out of the
inning and that's out number one
scoreless game
third inning ian happ coming up he
drives one toward left field deep back
goes carlson near the wall that ball is
gone
opposite field home run ian happ a
line smash cubs lead one to nothing
what a missile
well for ian's second hit of the ball
game and both of them are pitches down
in the zone
and that's exactly what ian needs to do
is make sure he gets the ball down
when he does he puts a great swing on it
and he
tones this ball to left field for a home
run bases are loaded this will be the
third time that dylan carlson
on this road trip in his young career
has come up with the bases loaded
little dribbler the out is at home they
get it
that's one three on for
fowler in a one-run game the one-two
serve
swaying in a miss strike three
strikeout number three comes at an
opportune time for you darvish
and now you got weeders up weeders they
got him to hit into a big double play
here earlier in the ball game
excellent job by you darvish the
cardinals loaded the bases with nobody
out and they
walk away empty-handed that is a
lead-off walk
a potential hit by tommy edmond on a
line out in the second
and he takes off and that's into the
right field corner
contreras should score easily
[Applause]
edwards going to try for a triple and he
will make it
two-nothing
[Music]
the new pitcher right-hander seth ellage
and his job is to keep the
runner from third and they are all
loaded up
for ian happ next pitch is a called
strike three on the inside corner good
delivery
from ellage and he catches hap looking
and it's up to anthony rizzo no place to
put
rizzo bases loaded and the pitch swing
and a mess he struck him out
and the cubs strand three here in the
fourth inning with wong and second and
two gone but maybe just maybe the
cardinals can get a run here or
a long fly ball for two runs off the bat
of paul goldsmith put two down
and goldsmith hits it into right that's
a base hit wong will score the cardinals
get on the board
and a key two out hit paul goldschmidt
and that cuts a lead to two to one
stormy weathers that'll play
out toward the bullpen nelson nearly
caught it
gonna be a play at second and he's safe
as bader played that hop perfectly and
baez has a double
[Music]
he wants the ball massacre
that'll bring up kyle schwarber who's
over two with a couple of strikeouts
no outs here in the fifth comes with a
man in scoring position
that'll go to run hard
kyle schwarber four to one
absolute no doubter a
patented swore bomb two seen fastball
running across the top of the zone
billy williams would love that swing
level and powerful and god
you darvish has a three-run lead working
now in the sixth
swing and a miss strike three harvest
has
six punch outs two outs for dexter
fowler
fowler strikes out two in the inning
they go one
two three for the first time tonight
cubs have runners at the corners with
only one out
carratini in the air deep right center
and it is
off the wall hayward's going to score
bodhi will stop at third base it's five
to one
oh so close
[Applause]
high fly fowler drifting
bodhi tags caratini tags
six to one on the sac fly let's have
runners at the corners with only one out
carratini in the air deep right center
and it is off the wall
hayward's gonna score bodhi will stop at
third base it's five to one
oh so close
high fly fowler drifting
boaty tags carratini tags
six to one on a sac fly and the cargo's
trailing in this ball game and now matt
carpenter
and the first pitch to carpenter ripped
into right field that's a base hit
over to cut it off it's hayward tommy
edmond will score to make it six to two
the bases are loaded and the tying run
will come to the plate
hits it left side and it's a double play
run scores 6-3 the new hurler
is rowan wick to face pinch hitter
andrew kisner
runners at first and third two in
six to three cubs lead wick on a 2-2
called strike three took it right down
the middle
cardinals settle for two